a ustedes no les pasa a menudo tener un
proyecto en la cabeza y levantarse un
día queriéndolo otro día odiando lo otro
día pensando que es increíble otro día
pensando que nada que no vale la pena
saben como la florecita el muñequito
animado clásico que va deshojando una
flor me quiere no me quiere me tira me
quita me quiten lo que quiere y que
acaba sin saber si lo quieren o no por
no ir a preguntar y con los pobres
flores y pétalos bueno tenemos un montón
de interlocutores mentales con quienes
conversar y como dependiendo el día uno
u otro está disponible entonces tenemos
la sensación de estar teniendo una
conversación dinámica que va a algún
lado un día me levanto y le digo al
soñador que le comento el proyecto y
acabo súper entusiasmado después habló
con el realista y acabó pensando que
quizás no vale la pena
yo personalmente paso mucho más tiempo
de que quisiera charlando con estos
amigos mentales juntos armamos asambleas
interminables en los que les damos diez
mil vueltas a los proyectos los
agrandamos los achicamos les los con
céntimos les damos palos los creamos y
los desechamos en una conversación casi
siempre inútil porque ya todos sabemos
que hasta que no involucramos al
exterior estamos especulando pero bueno
es un grupo muy selecto muy exclusivo
que se resiste a traer gente de afuera
así que no nos quedamos en pantanos
hablando de las mismas cosas por años y
entre los temas de conversación más
recurrentes que tuvo en estas asambleas
uno al que le y diez mil vueltas uno muy
especial por diferentes cosas de la vida
yo escribía algunas composiciones para
big band para los que no estén
familiarizados con el término big band
fue es una formación de más semanas 20
músicos que se popularizó durante los
años treintas no existiera amplificación
entonces la manera de tener salón de
baile en orden donde todos escucharon la
música era contratando orquestas y bueno
el arte de escribir para big band'
se ha movido mucho y
a cambiar digamos desde el swing de esa
época hasta piezas más contemporáneas de
concierto
durante mi paso por boston estuve
estudiando cuatro semestres y durante
ese tiempo escribí tres composiciones
para vivan que presente cuando me gradué
en uno de los conciertos que más
recuerdo como uno de los más especiales
de mi vida
[Música]
[Aplausos]
especial tanto que cuando me gradué de
la universidad que pensando que sería
chévere grabar esa música pero el
proyecto era enorme y decidí comenzar
por algo más realista y por re encontrar
la manera de ganarme la vida como músico
que se acaba de graduar de la
universidad
años más tarde el festival jazz al
parque en bogotá creó el a bogotá big
band y buscando músicos que pudieran
escribir para big band a encontraron
algunos vídeos míos en youtube de ese
concierto y me llamaron y durante tres
años seguidos escribí para la bogotá big
band pues ahora de repente tenía seis
composiciones escritas para big band de
las cuales estaba muy orgulloso estaba
súper feliz les había dedicado meses de
trabajo a cada una pero no había ninguna
sola grabación en vivo era así como en
la época de beethoven que escuchaban la
música una vez y ya y eso era muy
frustrante yo entonces obviamente ya
teniendo 6 me comenzó a dar vueltas
normalmente la idea de hacer un disco
para big band y ahí reactivar mis
asambleas mentales y nos quedamos ahí
patinando durante un buen par de años el
proyecto me generaba tantos
interrogantes que yo me quedaba medio
bloqueado pensando cómo va a conseguir a
los músicos de dónde va a conseguir la
plata será que vale la pena o no será
que la música es muy complicada
varias veces me acuerdo que en enero me
puse como propósito de año grabar la
música
al año siguiente estaba nuevamente con
el mismo propósito hasta que en algún
momento incluso mi cuñada me comentó que
con un tono así un poco sarcástico que
si no me cansaba de echar tanta carreta
en facebook en enero
porque la verdad que yo soñaba con
grabar esa música pero siempre todo se
me quedaban propósitos pero llegó un día
en el que ya estaba como tan frustrado
con esta cosa atravesada que decidí o
sea me pasó digamos el tema es que yo
venía trabajando con muchos músicos como
arreglista pianista pero después de cada
proyecto como la música no era mía el
artista con el que trabaja se llevaba su
proyecto y yo me quedaba añorando ese
concierto para big band que había hecho
años atrás entonces declaró ahora quería
hacer algo mío nuevamente entonces un
día eso estaba muy frustrado y me
levanté de mi asamblea mental ya harto y
decidí ponerme a trabajar entendí que de
esas reuniones conmigo mismo nunca iba a
salir esa grabación mente es de vivan
así que me senté en frente a mi
computador y comencé a man al email y al
poco rato ya tenía mi bandeja de gmail
llena de respuestas de amigos músicos
recomendándome otros músicos diciéndome
dónde podían ensayar felicitándome por
la música o sea que ya ahora en este
momento estaba desde el lado de la
acción y en muy poco tiempo avance más
que en años hablando conmigo mismo
con las agendas que me dieron los
músicos logré hacer una especie de tabla
un poco precaria que acabó siendo un
sudoku super complicado pero de la cual
logré dos días en las que todos o casi
todos los músicos podían ensayar así que
ahora tenía tres meses para hacer el
primer ensayo mis amigos mental estaban
impresionados mirándome como esto
arrancó
finalmente bueno llegó el día durante
tres meses estuve nadando en partituras
entonces el proyecto era enorme y 26
partituras y piezas largas o sea que
debo revisar y editar todo realmente era
un trabajo muy extenuante y llegó el día
en el que estaba enfrente de 20 músicos
en un salón y cada uno tenía enfrente su
partitura y estaba esperando que yo le
diera la entrada y arrancó la música
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bien
ah
pero finalmente ya estaba tocando la
música que había escrito y la música
estaba dialogando conmigo y con los
músicos y no con mis amigos mentales que
venían evaluando la desde hace años
tuve tres meses para preparar otros
ensayos no mentira unos diez meses para
probar unos 23 ensayos más y durante ese
tiempo estuve revisando las partituras
editando lo que hacía falta tomé algunas
clases de dirección me reuní con algunos
músicos para preguntarle si lo que les
estaba escribiendo se podía tocar y así
como lo podía mejorar línea cut con este
es el cerro de partituras antes de un
ensayo
y así seguí avanzando hasta que el
momento llegó el momento en el que la
música estaba sonando bastante bien y
bueno tenía que ya comenzar a pensar en
grabarla eso me enfrentaba con el
momento con la pregunta digamos que más
me ha atemorizado de todo el proyecto de
todo el proceso y es cómo podía
financiar esto
inmediatamente mis amigos mentales
empezaron a armar toda la asamblea para
preguntarme cómo iba a sacar la plata yo
había buscado becas y algún premio pero
pensé incluso en patrocinadores pero al
final me quedé con el recurso del
crowdfunding y salí a pedir plata en
algo que me generaba un montón de dudas
pero bueno antes de sentarme otra vez en
asambleas decidí mantenerme en el lado
de la acción y así seguir adelante
sigue adelante pensando cómo carajos lo
iba a hacer
y pensé en cómo comencé me senté me
acuerdo en frente de una cámara y
comencé a hacerme una entrevista en la
que poco conservadora en la clásica
entrevista de crowdfunding en la que
hola mi nombre es un andrés ospina y
estoy haciendo un disco para disparar
pero después de una mañana en teherán
esas me di cuenta que definitivamente
ese no era el camino yo quería hacer
algo con lo que yo me sintiera mejor y
se me ocurrió hacer un vídeo en el que
yo saliera persiguiendo a los músicos en
nueva york' en entornos digamos
cotidianos uno por uno buscando los como
si los estuviera grabando uno por uno
[Música]
a través de todo nueva york de punta a
punta con mi cámara en mi trípode
grabando a todos los músicos uno por uno
fue mucho porque me pude acercar más a
los músicos y conocerlos mejor también
hacía como que ellos involucran más con
el proyecto yo sabía que eso iba a
funcionar mejor a la hora de grabar si
éramos amigos y todos estábamos
involucrados pues si la música iba a
sonar mejor y finalmente bueno termine
el vídeo y ahora llegó el momento de
comenzar a prepararlo ahí genera un poco
un poco expectativa con fotos que poco o
nada decían de lo que estaba haciendo
aquí alguien me pregunta que que tanto
haces
finalmente llegó el día me decía el agua
tenía 32 y 35 días para recoger 32 mil
dólares durante ese mes estuve realmente
sumergido en el territorio de la acción
porque si me queda pensando un día ese
día no recolectada plata y un día que no
recolectada plata me aleja un montón de
la posibilidad de llegar a la meta y
tenía que conversar con toda la gente a
la que le gustaban las diferentes cosas
que yo hacía entonces de vídeos cómicos
muy ridículos y otros vídeos muy en
serio hablando con detalle de lo que
estaba haciendo la música o comentando
el proceso compuse una cumbia cuando
llegamos a los siete mil dólares
pero este de final del prote de 3 del
vídeo que salía dirigiendo los a todos
[Música]
ya que es me olvidaré
compuse una cumbia para cuando llegara
siete mil dólares
vamos ya tenemos en el tobillo desde
y compuso una samba 7
ya cuando llegamos a los 20 mil del
futuro escudo
[Música]
y alegría
y terminado bueno en la canción está
terminado con un mensaje que es una
pregunta que todavía me hago todos los
días como músico y es si nadie compra
discos cómo hacemos para grabar
sí
a
[Música]
y mi sobrina
bueno finalmente llegué a la meta
conseguimos que 600 personas de
diferentes países casi 600
vamos
bueno este momento en el que estamos
llegando para mí
así que fue una gran meta conseguir que
tanta gente se entusiasmara con un
proceso general principio de parecía tan
absurdo ahora venía el momento de
comenzar a grabar la música no entonces
durante varios meses estuve preparando
la grabación minuciosamente durmiendo
muy poco nadando en partituras llegó el
día y estuvimos durante más o menos tres
durante tres días en enero subimos en un
estudio muy importante nueva york
grabando con 26 músicos de diferentes
partes
fueron tres días muy intensos super
exigentes en los que aprendí muchísimo
hasta que finalmente bueno conseguimos
terminar la música los siguientes meses
estuve editando -la preparando toda la
masterización en la mezcla y luego los
artes con mi hermana esto es en algunas
artes que ella fue haciendo hasta que
finalmente llegamos a la portada del
disco y luego cuando el disco salió
salió una oportunidad es increíble es
como ir a tocar con la w era big band de
alemania un concierto espectacular luego
presentamos la música con la big band
con la que grabamos en el this is the
lincoln center de nueva york y después
alguien una gira con una big band que se
llama la tipo big band en dinamarca que
fue un proceso realmente increíble y
nada de lo que yo nada de lo que ocurrió
durante este proceso aparecía en esas
famosas asambleas mentales que tuve
durante tanto tiempo no en ningún
momento puede predecir cuando estaba
charlando conmigo mismo quiénes iban a
ser los músicos donde íbamos a tocar
cómo iba a ser la campaña cómo iba a
conseguir la plata que iba a pasar una
vez el disco saliera y básicamente no lo
podía saber porque realmente el azar se
confabula es cuando uno comienza a mover
las fichas que tiene disponibles en el
mundo real
resista puede tener una super estrategia
pero hasta que no hace la primera jugada
y comienza a conversar con las jugadas
del contrincante pues realmente no puede
saber si la campaña función si su
estrategia funciona o no además con cada
acción que yo tomaba me generaba un
compromiso entonces al principio me
comprometí a hacer un ensayo y eso me
obligó a hacer las partituras después
una vez hice un ensayo pues me compren
me comprometí a hacer un segundo ensayo
de un momento en el que ya había
ensayado y ahora tenía el compromiso con
los músicos de grabar la música pero
para eso necesitaba conseguir la plata y
una vez conseguí la plata tiene el
compromiso con la gente de terminar el
disco y todo lo comencé a ver como un
paso por paso que antes cuando estaba
hablando conmigo mismo ya era una bola
gigante de preguntas que no podía
resolver y me quedaba completamente
paralizado y yo para mí esto es una una
batalla constante porque gran parte mía
sigue insistiendo en las asambleas
mentales tengo algo que acordarme que
sin creatividad la imaginación poco
sirve como dice ken robinson en en su
libro el elemento la creatividad va un
paso más allá de la imaginación porque
requiere que uno de hecho se ponga a
hacer algo en vez de estar pensando en
ello
así que nada para que los que tengan
alguna idea o algún proyecto atravesado
acuérdense que lo que hay que hacer para
que comienza a suceder es salir a hacer
que comienza a que comience a suceder
dialogando con la acción y así que nada
vamos a hablar con la realidad y dejamos
a las florecitas ven quién no me quiere
me quiere
dejemos las críticas en el jardín muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]